كشفت مصادر العربيه في السعوديه عن بدء
الاولى مراحل تفعيل عيادات الادمان في
المستشفيات العامه بعد ما كانت عمليات
العلاج حصرا في المستشفيات النفسيه
المتخصصه وشملت المرحله الاولى من
المبادره الصحيه 50 مستشفى حول السعوديه
حيث جرى تدريب العاملين بها وتعريفهم
بعمليات علاج الادمان لتعزيز جوده الخدمات
المقدمه
استشاري الطب النفسي وقائد الطب الادمان
بوزاره الصحه الدكتور حسن الخبران دكتور
حسن حياك الله يفرجها الرابعه علاج
الادمان اصبح وعيادات علاج الادماء
الادمان اصبحت تتواجد في المستشفيات
العامه اريد ان اعرف كيف ستكون اليه
تطبيقها هو الفرق بينها وبين عيادات الامل
السابق
عيادات همم الادمان بالمستشفيات العامه هي
همم يعتبر مرض الادمان من الامراض النفسيه
وتوجد من صفات العامه عيادات طبيه نفسيه
تقدم الخدمات الطبيه النفسيه لكافه
الامراض منها همم طب الادمان ونظرا ل همم
بالتواصل مباشر مع بعض همم
المقدمين الخدمه افاده بوجود حاجتهم
للتعريف باليه التعامل مع الحالات اللي
همم
يكون لها حاجه لعلاج الادمان
فتم ترشيح عدد من المستشفيات
وقت عقد ورشه تدريبيه تدريبيه تعريفيه
بكيفيه التعامل مع مثل هذه الحالات كيفيه
تحويلها كيفيه التعامل معها ما هي الحالات
التي تعتبر ضمن نطاق الخدمه وما هي
الحالات التي تمر خارج نطاق الخدمه
الدكتور حسن المستشفيات اليوم لدينا هل هي
جاهزه فعلا لتستقبل هذه الحالات يعني احنا
نعرف انه في كثير مستشفيات مثلا يتم فيها
علاج بعض حالات الصحه النفسيه لكن الادمان
يعني مرحله معقده نوعا ما يعني في في
مساله الصحيه هل المستشفيات جاهزه على
الكوادر مدربه بشكل همم حتى يتم تعميم هذه
التجربه لا تقتصر فقط على 50 مستشفى صحيح
اتفق معك الانطباع الاولي والاساسي
للتعامل مع الادمان على انه همم مستوى
واحد الادمان مستويات فيه البسيط وفيه
المتوسط وفيه شديد همم توجد الكثير من
الحالات التي تفقد وهي في المرحله البسيط
والمتوسط والتي يمكن التعامل معها من خلال
عيادات من خلالفه بان هذا بين الادمان مرض
مزمن وانه يمكن علاجه من خلال خدمات
التاهيليه او من خلال الخدمات المتخصصه
همم في حال كان همم هو بحاجه الى تدخلات
اضافيه كثير من حالات تفقد يعني الامراض
الامراض الادمان المصاحبه تصلي نسبتها
بالنسبه للامراض النفسيه مصاحبه نسبتها
الى 40% وبالتالي 40% من الحالات 40% من
الحالات النفسيه قد يوجد همم الحالات
الادمان 40% منهم لديهم همم امراض نفسيه
واحد اخطر عوامل همم الوقوع في الادمان
وجود امراض نفسيه مصاحبه قد يكون بعض من
ياتون لديهم همم
بفحصهم همم يمكن توجيههم للخدمات
مصاصه في كان في حال كانوا بحاجه الى ذلك
طيب دكتور اليوم عندما تنتقل هذه العيادات
لتصبح المستشفيات العامه لتصبح اكثر من 50
مستشفى هل يعني ذلك انه لدينا حالات
متزايده في الادمان بالتاكيد كثير من
حالات تتجنب الذهاب المستشفيات المتخصصه
في مستشفيات الامل بسبب الوصمه وخلاف ذلك
فوجود مثل هذه الحالات يخف الوصمه يسهل
سهوله الوصول وهي تعتبر هذه المبادره هي
نواه همم لتفعيل دور همم النموذج الرعايه
الصحيه اللي يبدا من اسفل الهرم الى الى
الى اعلاء اشكرك جزيلا شكرا على وجودك معي
نشرت الرابعه الدكتور حسن خبراني استشاري
الطب النفسيه وقائد الطب الادمان بوزاره
الصحه شكرا